hi my name is Emma yang from the
TalkTalk up tackling cancer with the
Wolfram language and I'll be talking
about a lung cancer detection project
I'm working on
so hi I'm Emma I'm a mattress program
and I'm gonna be talking about the
program some products I've done in the
past and then a lung cancer project I'm
doing right now so first off let me
share some of the how it works with the
mentorship program so I've been working
with product using the Wolfram language
and to kind of learn about data science
and other things I'm interested in I
think me meeting weekly with my mentor
Andrea to kind of guide me through my
project and tackle any issues I'm having
so let me show you some of the projects
um where I've been working on so last
year I participated in something called
the opportunity project which was run by
the White House and it was to use open
data to create a tool to map out summer
meal sites for students who need it and
so I used open data through the Wolfram
data repository to do that and over the
summer I went to the high school summer
camp where I worked on a machine
learning project to identify road signs
so now I'm going to talk about the lung
cancer project I'm working at right now
so it was inspired by a data science
competition on Kaggle which is a
platform for people to share data sets
and hold competitions and their data
science Bowl this year was to improve
lung cancer detection so I wanted to use
how much data there was available to
kind of learn more about data science
and machine learning so let me talk
about little bit of the data that was
available so the first one was dated
that Kaggle provided by themselves which
included over a thousand patients worth
of CT scans and each of them it was
marked with whether or not they had
cancer but then through the forums I
also found a dataset called Luna 16
where you could not only have whether it
has cancer but you also have the
location of the nodules or the tumors
and then that's a subset of an even
largest that called
lig CI Duroc I DRI that has just nodule
locations and then also some
characteristics about those modules such
as malignancy and their size so I have
tried a couple approaches I'm going to
walk through some of them the first one
was to directly in
when approached I found on kaggle
through a tutorial which basically was
two training segments er to zoom in on
an area that was suspicious and then
used a cancer classifier to see whether
that area was cancerous or not so what I
found was that classifier can't take 3d
images so I had to take a 2d approach
and then I also found that a lot more
pre practicing listening it than just
putting in the classifier in order to
kind of specialize the classification
approach so after this I tried feature
extraction to see whether I could create
a more specialized classification
approach so the first one I tried was to
use the rate to quantify kind of the
shape of the lung by taking the ratio of
black pixels to non black pixels and to
see whether we can group cluster the
images by what kind of shape so you can
see that for the more regular shaped
images it works fine but when you get to
more irregular shapes it kind of gets
confused especially with more regularly
shaped lungs so I wanted to see why that
was and so I did a feature space plot
and we found that each of the curves of
each patient is slightly different and
so it's hard to pinpoint exactly a way a
direct way to kind of cluster the shapes
of each lung so now I'm working on this
like the current approach I'm working on
is based off of one of the Willing
winning solutions of the data science
Bowl which recently ended and so what
I'm doing first is to normalize all the
data and the scans through cropping them
because you see there's all this blank
white space that could be potentially
confusing the classifier so I wanted to
if you want to take that away you can
take a look at this pixel spacing
attribute and you in the or just found
in the metadata of each 2d slice and you
can see that for this one zero point
seven oh three and you can crap that
down to those image dimensions and get
in crop out most of the white space and
then after that I wanted to create my
training data so what I did is that I
got the X each CT scan 3d image contains
an XML file and that contains all the
data about nodules whether they're
cancer
and their location and some
characteristics about them so I used
mostly the Z position of the nodules
which shows you how high or low in the
lung it is to connect that with Z
positions in here which you can see it
with an image position and match whether
that 2d slice contain a nodule and you
can see that if it's false that means it
is how many nodules if it's true then
that means that contains nodules based
on this data so the step I'm working on
right now is to take a look at some
which of the neural networks is kind of
a most suitable for training with my my
data so the first one I'm using net
model to get some of the different
models that I could use with an image
classification and right now what I'm
working on is you see a test and those
out and seeing what happens for me the
next steps are going to be further
honing my model to include some of these
characteristics such as the malignancy
the diameter which is how big it is and
then some data about the structure of
the law of the nodules just take a look
at one of those will further enhance the
model and see one of those make it more
accurate so I'm going to go through some
of the most the biggest challenges for
me so one of them was to find the way
the right way to represent the data so
there I found various approaches through
the Kaggle platform some of them
involved making an actual 3d image out
of it and training as a bulk and then
some of them involved just training as
2d images all separately or 2d images
could have grouped together so finding
the right way to represent the data
based on my approaches and what I wanted
to try was one of the biggest challenges
for me and afterwards also trying to
write the way the right find the right
way to classify or model the data for
example we first tried clustering and
then in order to do feature extraction
now we're gonna do image classifications
of finding the right balance is also
something I'm working on and then lastly
find the right steps to accurately model
the patterns and the data so so the
first one we tried was a segment ER and
cancer classifier and then with the
feature extraction we tried a shape and
a cancer classifier and now we're doing
a more knowledgeable occasion based
classifier so I'm
I'm still trying to find which one is
most suitable and which ones I could mix
and match to see to make sure that we
cover all the bases so my goal for this
is to build a model that can accurately
predict the lung cancer and then maybe
down the road I could deploy it in a
real world scenario thank you
[Applause]